hey friends this is a daily Denney you
know we have been covering some huge
headlines all week long but you know
what I'm reclaiming my time and
dedicated today to music and boy do I
have a treat for you guys
we all loved guardians of the galaxy
because it doesn't get much better than
Chris Pratt Zoe Saldana and GRU but of
course another major draw was the
soundtrack in the sequel you can hear a
special 72 inspired tune from none other
than David Hasselhoff and now there is
actually a music video with the Hoff and
the guardian stars including Zoe to go
along with it and I've got your
behind-the-scenes sneak peek getting
down and dirty with Procyon Lotus they
kind of showed me at some videos that
were done back in the 70s and I had no
idea that it was going to be this nuts
the seventies wouldn't be what they work
wasn't for Cher so I was channeling my
inner chef and I got like this weight on
and everybody's like you know like
winking at the camera and doing like
this and it wasn't around the 70s so I
don't really know but it looks amazing
and super is it that ridiculous
and that's just a taste of it you guys
we have more from that video including
Chris Pratt's portion next week on ET
online and celebration of guardians
volume 2 digital release August 8 all
right but meanwhile Sam Smith has been
keeping a low profile lately presumably
working on his next record he's been
sharing pics from the recording studio
but he has since climbed out of his
bunker for an event in London on
Thursday and check this stud out the 25
year old hit the red carpet at the YSL
beauty club party I don't know if it's
the baggy long sleeve shirt and loose
jeans but my boy is looking noticeably
slimmer Sam of course has been working
on his fitness for a while now and he
kept it real with us about keeping the
weight off when we last spoke with him
at the 2016 Grammys it's hard to like
really get in shape but to maintain and
I think it's something harder and you
are looking better and better thank you
very much it's very very difficult I
love food
so the combat so it's always going to be
a bathtub and Charma bet are we all just
trying our best
you look good kid alright moving right
along to a performance everyone is
talking about it's been trending all day
One Republic paid tribute to the late
Chris Cornell and Chester Bennington
this morning on Good Morning America
the band filled in for Linkin Park who
had to pull out of their GMA appearance
following Chester's death and they were
joined on stage by Cornell's
twelve-year-old daughter Toni they
performed an emotional rendition of
Leonard Cohen's Hallelujah the same song
Bennington sang at Cornell's funeral in
may take a look
[Music]
ah
just before the performance Chris's
daughter said it was an honor to sing
for her dad and Chester it was an
emotional and rainy morning over there
in New York City and the same could be
said for the folks over at Lollapalooza
Music Festival in Chicago last night
the city and festival organizers were
forced to end the first night of the
festerly and evacuates festival goers
due to an approaching storm
that means attendees missed out on
headlining sets from Muse Porter
Robinson and Lorde
that's right that is Lorde right there
soaking wet and blowing a kiss after she
was forced to cancel her set she said
she was gutted and tweeted fans this is
the most melodrama thing ever
and promised fans she returned to
Chicago soon but fear not Lorde fans you
might not have got a chance to see or
perform live at la la' but thankfully
the singer dropped a new video for her
next single perfect places the song
kicks off our new music Friday pics so
check it out
[Music]
Hey
I
[Music]
now if you thought Lord sing into a
lightbulb with silly
wait until you see macklemore's music
video for marmalade it features a young
king of the Mack rolling around his
Mercedes with a mini little yachty
celebrating these icons but you know I
[Music]
can't see my face I'll be back I am
obsessed with that one okay finally ed
Sheeran is taking us to gun out with
this video for his new single baby I baa
nailed it I have been practicing that
all morning are you guys here is a
tropical jammer for you someone told
always say what's on your mind and I am
own being honest with you I get along I
made mistakes from time to time Sinanan
Cory baby having a year Hey all right
baby I baa translates to all will be
well so I leave you with that mantra
before the weekend we'll be tracking
stories all weekend long so be sure to
head to ET online.com for the latest and
we'll be back on Monday so hit that
subscribe button
alright imma dance my way out here happy
Friday everybody TGIF
whoo